assalamualaikum
welcome back to the four muslims the
realest podcast in the dunya make sure
you smash that like button i've never
said that before bro make sure you smash
that like button rate comment and
subscribe
how are we doing boys
how you been how you been
i'm doing really well thank you
listen i'll give you five stars for the
intro and for your youtube channel
martial the algorithm is going to work
with your channel all right well thank
you real quick how did you find our
channel bro
through anger he made the um
i'm a muslim now video about a year ago
and then he also mentioned that he was
doing the podcast with you guys
okay okay
man
last time we spoke there were a few
things that you said you had on your
mind like questions you wanted to ask us
right but before we jump right in
tell us a little bit about your journey
bro for anyone that doesn't know what
self-improvement or kaizen or anything
like that is tell us about your journey
bro
okay
so i was born in pakistan
and we moved to the uk when i was a few
years old and i was raised as a muslim i
was uh
we used to go to the mosque as well and
my mom taught me the sapara and i always
like fought against i didn't want to
read it i didn't really understand it
and
as i got older and older i kind of took
a big step back away and i saw science
and
um
went a lot more like western and
degenerates and found the red pill and
casual sex and drugs
then self-improvement really began for
me
in
2020 i took a step back from that
lifestyle
essentially i achieved the lifestyle
that the um
the hedonism pushed me towards i
achieved everything that i thought i
really wanted i slept with many girls i
took many drugs went to parties did
everything and i hated my life after
doing that for like two years so moved
back
um
took a step back away from everything
everyone moved back home to my family's
house no friends no girlfriend no
nothing and i literally just started
meditating and reading books and posting
my learning lessons with my developments
online and then those videos just kind
of popped off so i talk about the
conventional things you see in a young
man's self-improvement so building
strength going to the gym discipline no
fap
i try to speak more and more about
healthy relationships although that's
definitely an area that i need to learn
more about myself as well
i was just changing the the thing to a
slow-mo bro because people are spamming
the comments alhamdulillah
but all that being aside when you
mentioned that it led you to
um you mentioned in a few videos at
least that you know you've changed your
views a couple times there's this one
video where you you even you know
verbatim you said that you know i'm
admitting that you know all the things
that i've i've learned some of them
might not be correct at least in terms
of the red pill and i want to be the
first one to say for myself and i know
for the other two brothers here that we
used to follow the red pill too to a
certain extent right
there's elements of truth in everything
right there's elements of truth and red
pill there's elements of truth in a lot
of ideologies right but it doesn't make
it objectively true right we're going to
get into what objective truth even means
for a lot of the viewers that don't know
but before we go on anha rami bro
anything on your minds
have a random question bro when you say
when you say that you found science what
did that mean
how did that change your perspective
i guess because of my
upbringing with my family i was taught
about islam and allah and then going
through the education system and you
start
um learning about science and the big
bang
and
that's also when like the kids around me
would also say like oh you know like
religion god's not real and everything
and of course like
i totally believe it like even still to
this day it's like it's one of those
where
i've i've had that mindset for so long
that it feels
so normal for me to not consider any
kind of higher power
wow
wow subhanallah yo wait till ramy tells
you about you know someone how literally
science essentially came from muslims
majority of the modern science that we
have today came from muslims bro but the
western education system along with a
lot of things like you know feminism and
all this they're going to throw a lot of
these things that don't make sense bro
just to throw us off our square yeah
yeah we'll get to that we'll get to that
eventually
it is a big problem so uh
uh on hill bro how about you
now let's just dive in bro i'm excited
all right
let's get into it
all right so the first thing that i
wanted to
genuinely ask you bro
living in this this red pill i guess
centric world where you were saying that
you were living a hedonic life right you
would you were following the things that
most you know people were following
youtubers you made that video saying
that red pill youtubers and you you kind
of exposed them right
tell us a little bit about that because
we've been speaking about that on our
channel for a while that there are
truths in red pill being red pill aware
and stuff like that but essentially we
see it lead to a road where it just
leads to no morality anymore you know
what i mean
yes they understand female nature yes
there's evolutionary psychology and
behaviorism right no one's denying that
but there's no morality there's no
conscience you know what i mean so tell
us a little bit about that video they
made
um okay um
the the truths of the red pill only seem
like jaw-dropping because
we've adopted such like backwards blue
pill thinking that men and women are the
same and so the truth really is just oh
yeah men and women are different and so
of course women are attracted to
different things and a lot of it's just
based on like the biological differences
between men and women and so there's
like there's certain facts which i
really found uh very interesting like
women will
prefer men who show more dominance and
alpha characteristics of higher
testosterone when they're over ovulating
when they're able to get pregnant and
that's kind of something that you're not
really taught about here because you
thought you know be nice be yourself but
there's biological proof that
there is really that tendency of like al
alpha fox can i can i swear around here
okay it's better if you don't we'll edit
that okay my apologies alpha f and then
they are box
but um so there is there is beautiful
truth to it i think it's very important
that young men get that knowledge
because you don't hear it in the in like
western societies at least i've only
ever grown up in the west i'm not too
sure in different countries but we hear
that men and women are the same we
should be treated equally and whilst
there is like some need of equality
you can certainly go like too far with
that to the point that now boys think
that they should behave like girls and
girls think that they should behave like
boys and now we're all
just dead inside because of that that
lack of polarity so the issue then with
the red pill because so far it sounds
great but the issue then is that
you've got to kind of understand like
the red pill is more just kind of the
belief system
but
the biggest influences of the red pill
are degenerates they're the type of guys
who already had a messed up self-image
that they found that knowledge they
implemented it for the fastest version
of intimacy that they could get which is
casual sex and then they're also the
guys who had the level of self-image
that was already broken to then post
about it online and tell other guys
here's how you can hook up with girls
from the club
and so
by following the red pill
a young man is
naturally gonna come across those child
channels where he
learns directly from a guy whose main
goal was pleasure and the guys lie about
it and they say like no you know the
main goal should be purpose and
everything be on your purpose but the
truth is like the entire channel is
focused on casual sex
and so at least for me like i take
responsibility that that became my
biggest goal and the idea is oh you know
like i'm on my purpose i'm going to the
gym and everything but it's all fueled
by the desire of casual sex because you
grow up as like a little loner
directionless purposeless
and then here's finally you know and
you've tried you've been on tinder and
you've been messaging girls and
nothing's happening
and
here's finally like the truth the guys
are saying oh yeah well you know you
here's how you can get the number
clothes here so you can get the lay
clothes like you can go to the club and
like sleep with the first girl that you
see well just follow these easy tactics
one i think the biggest criticism i have
which i mentioned in that video it's
titled uh red pill youtubers are
traumatized
that by following these kind of
degenerates cold-hearted tactics so some
of them are like you know don't message
her back treat her bad in a sense
you're just automatically gonna filter
out all of the good women who actually
have any kind of respect for themselves
all that's left is like those club
thoughts
they're the type of girls who are going
to be more attracted to a guy who for
example doesn't message them back and
that's like that's got to be saying
something if the girl is more attracted
to you because you're not speaking to
her
like that's really messed up
and so at least that's like that's the
the whole that i found myself in
subhanallah bro first thing i want to
say is the thing you were talking about
men and women having polarity and women
having different mate preferences in
different times of the month and if
they're on you know birth control and
all that we literally dropped the video
yesterday about that subhanallah and
that's the thing bro like islam like has
been saying these things from jump
street from day one we're not shy about
these things but the thing with red pill
feminism to a certain extent all these
isms is they're they're creating
man-made constructs because they don't
have divine revelation and you can do
that and you can be right you know
sometimes but you can also be wrong
sometimes right second thing i want to
say is i want to give you some praise
bro mashallah for your hamza and for the
hamza unfiltered channel
you were dropping some stuff there that
when you're basically projecting this
red pill ideology and you're taking
things that these youtubers you know
so-called are putting things as
literally like matter of fact you're
only going to attract that type of woman
right
you you you leave a girl on scene and
she gets hooked to that well then you're
basically going to get a damaged woman
that's into that right so
you know you saying these things a lot
of youtubers aren't right a lot of
youtubers i see in the red poster are
hypocrites bro and i'm i'm not here you
know attacking any youtubers right now
you do your thing but
how are you gonna make a video about
nofap and semen retention but then your
clickbaity thumbnail is literally gonna
cause someone to go watch
you know what i mean like i've seen so
many of youtubers do that and i don't
see that with you and and and a few
other youtubers too alhamdulillah if
you're talking about semen retention or
nofap it literally stays with that
you're not gonna trap someone or bait
someone into staying in this cycle where
they need the youtuber now you know what
i mean
so that's first and foremost um the
second thing i wanted to touch on was
when you said that
it leads to a place where you're
following people that are hurt or
traumatized or they're literally arguing
with thoughts bro i agree i'm not gonna
make i'm not gonna name the the channel
by name right now but there's so many
channels that are literally arguing with
thoughts
about women and they're leading a life
where they're telling you to treat women
and only attract women and and create
the type of woman that they're claiming
to to say that we should avoid do you
get what i mean like you're you're every
time you're you're having casual sex or
every time you're like okay there's
there's a side check but there's a main
chick bro every time you're with that
side chick you're literally creating
another thought you're creating another
issue
of what you're talking about you know
what i mean
there is a huge problem with integrity
in that circle and that's what made me
feel
only when i had the level of
accountability of posting uh the stuff i
was doing and then my boys were calling
me out for it otherwise i would have
never really thought about it but you've
gotta lack integrity by posting red pill
content and by engaging in that life
because the argument is okay you know
women are so bad like women are evil in
the dating market and there's there's so
many like ultrasexual women who um
are like manipulative they're all
thoughts and the channel that you're
mentioning of course we all know which
one it is
and that makes sense okay fair enough if
you're going to be living like a
faithful man who's married and who never
like
engages in the behavior that causes that
otherwise you are part of the problem
and i realize yeah 100 i'm part of the
problem i'm i'm
preaching against this i'm talking about
the the detriments of this lifestyle and
i'm causing more of those girls to
become like that
and it was only the accountability of my
followers who saw those videos called me
out for it criticized me for and
obviously like it hurt my ego they're
they're definitely wrong i'm right i'm
the one who's getting laid here that
eventually i decided to think okay
people i respect the same this to me now
like i've got to take it seriously it's
not the right path
last week or two weeks ago we reacted to
a video that you made two muscle women
in the jacuzzi bro
and what you were saying i just want to
touch on this right now before we go on
it's facts bro especially as someone
that
i don't you don't consider yourself a
muslim yet right i'm the liberal
but
being a non-muslim per se and and just
being someone that isn't on dean
you saying the things that
the dean basically means like
our faith you know and rami can correct
me if i'm wrong but being on deen means
you're on the right path on the straight
path right it's just the same
um you're practicing it means you're
you're actually practicing like that's
your way of life
everyone has a deen you know like
self-improvement is a deen
but in islam like the dean is like you
you're practicing like you're actively
practicing
okay
yes
but
basically you
you're not on dean
in terms of you know practicing islam
but you you have that core fundamental
you know understanding of
you know modesty and hijab right now in
the video you did say like imagine how
like badass it is a woman respects you
so much that she only wants to reveal
her skin to you yes that is one
tenet of it but the main reason that you
know we as both men and women bro we
have
modesty right
in islam we have to cover up certain
parts of our body that are different
among men and women
but we both have that right and we do
this first and foremost for allah
because we have
hayah we have modesty in in in terms of
like shyness you know what i mean to
some extent like we don't want to over
show and we have to abide by that at all
times especially in public
and women that are single as well have
to abide by that right so i just want to
make that that one thing clear
if some people are are taking what you
said and they're like oh yeah it's good
i understand bro it's good for for your
man 100 but single women single muslim
women have to abide by that too and
single muslim men definitely have to
abide by that too so it's it's like a
bonus in a way when you you're doing
that and you're you know only your
spouse can see you
but it's something that all muslims have
to do bro
but that aside bro
what is your
idea or your definition of masculinity
because i want to ask you that and i
want to basically get a clear
understanding of all the ups and downs
you've been through and and how you
currently at this moment in time see
masculinity
that's a good question
so my my thought process and my answer
for this changes quite regularly
depending on which book or which author
i've been recently reading
and if you ask me this question a couple
of years ago i would i would say
masculinity is about being a man and i
wouldn't really have had any real answer
after that i still don't feel like my
mind is made up at all
but
in my mind i see the vision of
what seems like an old-school man an
old-school relationship
where the man takes responsibility he's
the leader
he is the provider
i see a group of men
in like this
sense of
camaraderie
brotherhood
growing together but there's also like a
level of of
growth like
criticism with each other but like
friendly with through love
i think
i really love the quote from jack
donovan the way of men
is the way of the gang
and i think a lot of masculinity is
based on the brothers that you have
around you
okay what's your uh like definitional
vision of masculinity now
my
i'll i'll tell you mine and then angel
and and rami can jump in but
in islam we have the quran right we
believe the quran a lot of people think
it's just a book
yes it's on you know paper but the quran
is just the word of allah the word of
god and when god has sent us divine
revelation we'll talk about different
religions in a bit too but i don't want
to get into a side tangent but he sent
down the message right
it got altered in all religions most
religions but he promised that in in the
quran he would preserve it right
in the quran
very clearly tells us the rights and
responsibilities of men and women right
this is a huge point and we have the
prophet peace be upon him prophet
muhammad that has taught us that too all
right
now
prophetic and divine revelation of
masculinity essentially has roles
and responsibilities and also rights
right
and that's different than women so when
people a lot of people think for some
reason that the prophet peace be upon
him was a feminist because he gave women
rights no he gave women rights because
women and men deserve rights but
in islam we don't give women rights at
the expense of men like feminism does
and we don't give men rights and value
and pleasure at the expense of women
like a lot of red pill coaches are
preaching right
so in islam the rights and
responsibility for rose a masculine man
right who who's in touch with fitrah
right i want to touch on the fitra point
too because a lot of people don't know
what that means i'm sure you don't
either right
yeah the fitra is basically our innate
i guess predisposition right every
single human being was born with a
correct and sound fitrah right we you
know how you were saying a couple
minutes ago that like for some reason
you couldn't just shake off that belief
in god that belief in one god like that
one higher power that's your fitra bro
everyone's born with that fitra
everyone's born a muslim you know it's
just society and parents and all that
that changes us but anyway the point is
the fitra of a masculine man is one who
protects right protects
at the expense and cost of his own life
puts his own life on the line for his
loved ones
provides right so provisioning
and this is this is very different than
a lot of red pill coaches because
they're going to say you know beta bucks
you know you can't you can't be that
beta male provider listen being a beta
male provider is just being a provider
to a thought that hasn't earned anything
being a provider to your wife and to
your kids is a different thing bro it's
a different ballgame right but if only
these people these perks knew but that's
that's one thing being a man in terms of
being the leader right
i'm the leader of the relationship the
marriage you know i i decide this is
left and this is right by divine
revelation not just something i pull out
of thin air
and i'm gonna do my best to keep the
family on this course on this track
right
these are the things that make a man a
man this is masculinity and first and
foremost keeping the covenant you have
with allah
keeping the relationship you have with
allah first and foremost
nothing else compromises that it's not
going to be a job it's not going to be a
woman it's not going to be anything
but this is how i would describe it
[Music]
and what's beautiful bro is that
uh number one is never changing it
always remains the same and number two
any man who actually looks at this and
like really just reflects on this like
it it aligns it aligns with something
that they can't even explain and that's
that thing that they can't explain is
exactly what fire said
it's the thing inside of us so it's like
this is masculinity this is the
masculine role and then when the
feminine role is
spoken about in the quran
that also aligns with women if they can
just stop and reflect on it if you don't
have a feminist
it sounds really
um
really good
like it i can see that that must have
been so beneficial for you guys to have
like a huge level of certainty with that
because like you with my answer for this
question is like it's based on some like
random author from this book it's based
on like some random blog
it sounds
so much nicer to have such a certain
thing that you guys have been following
yeah well it's that's that's the case i
think a lot of the time when it comes to
religion in different aspects when it
comes to morality when it comes to
belief when it becomes when it comes to
purpose you can't say any any of these
things are objective without religion
without god like how can you you know
how can you prove uh giving charity is
good you can't prove it you can only
kind of argue for it like oh it helps
them why is it good to help people you
know it's a long line and same thing
with more uh with morality and
masculinity because masculinity is not
one of those things that you type in you
know google what's masculinity and it
gives you exactly what it is it's so
encompassing it's like everything a man
should be it's like well what does
everything a man should be well it's
this it's this it's a long ends up being
a long list so you you're gonna have
people that disagree like i think a man
should provide it's like no i think a
man should you know be able to provide
but blah blah and people come up with
other different answers when it comes to
religion as uh the brothers were saying
we have our fitrah we have exactly how
god created us to be and exactly how god
created us to act
and within this we see very beautiful
hadith and this is for all people not
just men but like the hadith of the
prophet peace be upon him who i'll get
to in a minute insha'allah where he said
that the strong believer is better and
more beloved to god than the weak one
but there's good in everyone
how beautiful is that he says he's good
in everyone right everyone has good in
them but the strong person is better
than the weak person and more beloved to
god why because they can do more
they can do more and that's just it's
not just physically it could be
financially it could be mentally it
could be intellectually could be in many
many different ways you know a strong
public speaker is better than someone
who is not a strong public speaker and
there is a time when i you know i'm not
going to say i'm a great public speaker
but there was a time when i was too shy
to even stand in front of three people
and speak
and now hunger down in front of everyone
here but um
that's basically the the blessing in
islam and the ultimate blessing
is when you look to the prophet peace be
upon him you could see the bravery you
could see the courageousness you could
see the
the masculinity of the prophet saws but
you can also see the empathy you could
also see the south side you can also see
the emotional intelligence you have two
sides
the first side is when there is a big
a big like basically not the big bang
with the universe but a big bang like a
loud like loud funk a loud noise a loud
almost explosion kind of you know ear
rattling nerve wrecking sound and in the
middle of the desert you don't hear a
lot of that you hear here you're like
they're doing construction right in the
middle of the desert you hear a big
noise you're like what the heck was that
when the people were kind of speculating
what is it you know i'm getting ready to
go check it out the prophet they saw the
prophet muhammad was already on his way
back he was already on his way back from
seeing what it was he came
on a horse i believe without a saddle
even
and he said don't worry i checked it out
it's nothing you have that bravery the
man who fought in the words the man that
fought in battles
and the man that never
gave up you know he was persecuted for
years he never gave up and
he a follower who's persecuted is
difficult but being a leader who's
persecuted is even more difficult
because you yourself are persecuted and
the people you are in charge of taking
care of are persecuted as well so that's
difficult so you had that side but you
also had the side of the prophet peace
be upon him when he was basically laying
close to his wife in bed and one of his
wives
can you guys still hear me want to make
sure bro yeah yeah
so he was laying next to one of his
wives
and she got her period so you know she
kind of crept out of bed and without
without trying to disturb him and she
kind of kind of like embarrassed and
shot you know yeah she's clearly shy
about it it's not something she wanted
to tell a prophet
and the prophet noticed that right he
noticed it so before she crept away too
far he asked
uh basically like did you start your
period
and she's like yeah
so he wanted to show first that he
acknowledges it and secondly he said
okay when you come back come back even
closer to me than you were before
to show her that it's not something to
be grossed out about i don't mind i
don't care you're my wife i love you i
want to be close to you small things
like that so you have both sides and in
that we have as allah says in the quran
the perfect example for mankind and
that's why it's so clear for us it's not
just do this and do that it's here is a
man who literally lived the life that
you should be living
bro i want to touch on something real
quick right now
the adonis character that hamza keeps
talking about in his videos subhanallah
like it's in characteristics and in in a
lot of the the traits it's it's almost
aligned with the prophet saw now i'm not
making a comparison between the two
whatsoever but a lot of the the things
that you're saying like jeffrey does
this jeffrey does that jeffree's blue
pill jeffrey's a spoke but adonis is
this he's not he's not too you know into
this side of the extreme but he's also
not too into this side of the extreme
right he's perfectly balanced and he's
dominant not in terms of being
domineering to other people but being
dominant over his own self which is
which is the most difficult form of
dominance to attain for the modern man
and this was the prophet of sombra in
every way
the the prophet peace be upon him has
maintained perfection and mastery just
like rami was saying right he was never
too this way he was number two that way
he had emotional intelligence but he was
very dominant he was very masculine and
i think that these are the types of role
models that people are lacking today
they're like oh what author too should i
follow him what youtuber should i follow
the issue with this is when you follow
someone and you glorify them to such a
degree when they're not divine i guess
sent divinely sent role models
you fall victim to this echo chamber
where you take everything they say is
truth i'll give you an example there's a
youtuber ams right everyone knows ams
bro this there's some good stuff he says
bro but there's some some sleazeball
stuff he says and he's shameless about
it too
if you follow him to a certain extent
that you're like i'm going to follow
everything he says i'm just following
ams then it's like if he says something
that's objectively wrong right
then you're kind of going to be a victim
to that right but when you follow
someone like the prophet peace be upon
him just like you were saying hamza that
it gives you peace because you you have
that surety that that certainty it
really does bro because before that i
was like okay i would follow this one
youtuber until this point
and then i'd find a new youtuber right
now it's like i have that consistency
it's like set in stone
i have felt that's been uh a problem
being like an influencer a leader
because as i give my own
self-improvement
uh learning lessons like my channel was
never really meant to be this big
honestly it was literally just i was
just sat downstairs recording oh yeah
like i've been meditating and this is
what i learned and i would give quite
unconventional advice compared to what
like the big youtubers were saying and i
felt like there was way more value in me
just being unfiltered authentic and
literally saying word for word like the
bad habits like in detail whereas a lot
of the big youtubers they kind of like
cover it up and i thought there was like
a um
like hidden point like point of value
that could be gained for some random guy
who's you know watching this but as i
gained more and more of an influence and
it went to like three hundred thousand
it was about 150k when i realized like
these people are following every word
that i say and there was multiple times
where i made some pretty big mistakes
and i said some stupid advice and
it you know
it took me a while to realize that this
is actually serious it was when i did a
visualization and i i visualized like a
politician getting ready for a speech
they're going to address 60 000 people
80 000 people like that's that's a big
thing that politician is going to be
briefed beforehand they're going to
prepare a script they're going to be
consulting body language experts and
here i was like i don't even get changed
before my videos i just shut up the
camera just say whatever comes up off
the top of my mind and so i said some
stupid stuff i've praised the wrong
things and i've minimized the right
things
and so the the idea of adonis then was
almost like
a
a practice of
humility for myself to say like okay
that's where you you guys should be
aiming for not me i've got it on my wall
behind me to to make men more like
adonis and not my like myself because
as a human being like we make so many
mistakes and if someone's goal is to
strive towards being like me
they're gonna make the exact same
mistakes that i did and wise men learn
from those mistakes so they don't have
to make them themselves it seems like if
you're religious if you practice islam
like
you've got such a clear path in front of
you
to follow what's already an organized um
how would you say like what's already a
all positive
role model
i agree with the bro all positive but
first and foremost truth
as as close to truth as you can get
where you can follow red pill and you
can go on this route and then you can
find out okay this was right this was
wrong
you can follow feminism like for women
that want to be you know brainwashed and
programmed
and then you can be hopefully you know
because most of them they they just look
like they're too into that to even have
that self-awareness um but you can
realize okay they're saying it you can
follow anything but all we're saying is
why waste your time why not have
something that will literally tell you
that from the beginning that this is
literally it this is the straight path
you know and i love that you mentioned
that in another video too you said that
you know
these people these muslims they look
like they're you know imagine fearing
allah and knowing that you're going to
be held accountable by allah how are you
going to do something you know bad
when you said that in that video i i
innately just resonated with that as a
muslim because we know first and
foremost that
doing you know in red pill they're like
oh do this you know how to not get
caught let's say for example if you want
to cheat on your spouse right
we know that
it's easy to fool a girl
no one let's not cap it's it's no it
doesn't it's not you know rocket science
or anything to fool another human being
but how are you gonna fool allah who's
always watching right
and this is the this is the difference
between the man the believer and someone
who's not a believer right if you're a
believer you know that you are going to
be questioned and you were going to be
judged and and you know assessed for
every single deed that you committed you
know
and your sins are not going to be you
know forgotten just because no one
caught you right in in western law this
is this is the issue right what's the
speed limit bro on the speed let's say
like 100 kilometers an hour right
a lot of people are speeding bro only
some people get cut right so these
people are not speeding because or these
people are not not speeding when there's
a cop there because they want to
actually you know protect the law and
submit to the law they're just not
speeding because they don't want to get
caught you know what i mean here it's
not about getting caught or not getting
caught because we know that we're caught
and we're booked 24 7. right so
that in and of itself gives people a
little bit of an ego death but i don't
want to get too much into that but tldr
it gives you an immense level of
accountability and responsibility first
and foremost from allah right people can
say whatever but you got to be solid 24
7. and i believe as a man that is the
most masculine thing that you could do
which is constantly be mindful of that
people that are into meditation they
know about that and
it's not easy bro it's much easier said
than done yeah yeah that's true and just
to piggyback off that point i want to
give an example that uh angel gave since
the beginning
he basically the examples like when you
when you're trying to put an ikea piece
together a piece of furniture or
something from ikea
you could do it with an instruction
manual and basically know exactly what
you're doing or you can throw it away
and just try and do it yourself
and maybe you'll get it right maybe
you'll get it wrong maybe you'll get
some parts right you'll leave maybe a
screw out here or there and not get it
fully right because you're doing it
yourself you're trying to figure out
yourself and that's something as simple
as putting together a piece of furniture
that's designed to be put together
based on the manual or based on the
pieces even you can kind of put it
together in your mind imagine something
as complex as life
with morality with right with wrong with
good with the bad with emotion with with
uh everything basically everything life
has to offer
you can either just with your limited
knowledge and your biases and your your
desires which are all forces that are
driving you already try and figure it
out yourself
and this is the funny part even if let's
say you figured it out perfectly you
won't even know that you did
you won't even know because how can you
prove it you can
so you can try and never get there
or
you can have an instruction manual from
the one who created you and created life
and that's what dean is actually a more
definitive answer and the brother the
brother said they were right but a more
definitive more descriptive definition
is a full system of life that encompass
encompasses our belief and our actions
both our belief and our actions
so we know what to believe because god
reveals to us what is true in terms of
god existing the angel existing heaven
and hell day of judgment all that stuff
but he also tells us how to live life
what can you do what can't you do
there's not a thing or an action on the
face of the earth
that islam doesn't say yes it's allowed
or it's not allowed or it's permissible
it's preferred it's disliked there's
some kind of ruling for it that comes
from the quran
and from the prophet muhammad peace be
upon him and that's what islam is it's
an answer for life
not just man's greatest questions of oh
how did i get here what am i doing here
where am i going
it answers those but it also answers
sorry i got a call it also answers is it
beneficial for me to do this should i do
this should i not is this right is this
wrong and what is a man
bro i was laughing at those comments man
saying that if hamza becomes muslim
he'll perfectly be the fourth muslim and
all will say his army you know insha
allah if god wills um
but hamza bro what's what's on your mind
because what rami is saying about this
this complete way of life
this is only found in islam bro
other religions comparative religions we
can talk about that on the next podcast
right but there's there's a there's
another major religion i don't want to
name it by name right now because people
are going to get triggered but
it has
belief which we call akita right but it
doesn't have sharia like the rights and
wrongs being questioned that moral
conduct you believe in this and then
you'll be saved you'll have salvation
you don't have to have a level of
conduct in your lives you're not going
to be questioned on what you do but in
islam we don't have that bro you you
can't guarantee that just because you
say you'll believe you're not going to
go to hell right there has to be this
this level of right and wrong haram and
all that
was that
accountability accountability exactly
bro mohammed bro what's up
um
so i said that in the video that i made
that
if you do
i think it was the the two muslim women
in the jacuzzi video and i said that if
you for those women if they believe in
islam then you have a god level of
accountability and we say in
self-improvement accountability is like
one of the most important factors it's
what everyone's paying a personal
trainer for
and uh
it's what you just said that
it's always there when you were saying
that i made me think like you guys must
be you must have so much integrity to
those values
because you know what like i've always
noticed this concept that
i will act in a certain way when there's
viewers when there's someone who's there
but you have someone there watching you
all all the time
so
the example i gave ages ago was that
i'll i'll always run faster if i want to
run i'll always run faster if there's
other people especially women there so
when i'm by myself there's no one around
i'll like i'll slow down i'll get tired
and if there's like a group of girls
who's my age or something like i'll run
faster
but it's like i know it's an autistic
example but i feel like you guys would
like run faster but like all the time
yeah
bro it's it goes back to this thing
known as taqwa aqua is god consciousness
it's you're constantly aware that
oh god is always there
right and it it goes back to what we
were saying in the beginning like
i'm about to get back to you in a second
bro i completely just
lost my train of thought for real for
real honestly
that's exciting i'm gonna give a quick
disclaimer to anyone that is you know
sending a super chat or or uh you know
you're a youtube member we're gonna get
us and hamza tan so your questions all
at the end we're gonna do like a little
20 minutes set aside 30 minutes set
aside at the end for q a but we're just
going to try to keep the main section of
the podcast unfiltered but yeah bro
pertaining to this whole taqwa this god
level of accountability
you're right bro
you know you're saying you guys must
live your life you know like
like you know solid and and this it's
like we're still we're still human
beings bro so i want you to understand
this that we still sin right and we're
not gonna air our sins but you know
we're not supposed to do that as muslims
but we still sin bro the prophet peace
be upon him said every son of adam is a
sinner
the best of those that are those that
repent
you know so there's no denying that
we're all sinners we're not going to be
here with this false pious you know that
you know we don't sin or anything we're
not supposed to but we're all sinners
bro but at the end of the day like one
of the the pi i believe it was a pious
predecessor or one of the companions of
the prophet peace be upon him he said
that if i disobey allah
i i reckon the effects of it in the
behavior of my wife or the camel that i
ride
i want to talk about this for a bit
because you know
first of all let me ask you bro when you
hear this what's your interpretation
before i tell you
say it again please yeah so when i
disobey allah i reckon the effects of it
in the behavior of my wife or the camel
that i ride
when he goes against uh his integrity
his values
he notices like maybe a lack of respect
from his wife or his camel and like more
problems in his life
100
this is one thing that i want to speak
on just personally after you know being
on
i noticed the effects of slip ups in
exact real time
when i was before islam you know red
pill or following anything else it's
like
i would go deeper into my disobedience
to allah i would go deeper into just
doing whatever and being in this echo
chamber but right now when you genuinely
understand allah loves you and you have
the connection to try to like please
allah right
if you even do a minor slip up you'll
notice this bro in your life and i think
this in and of itself is a blessing bro
hamza have you noticed anything like
that in your life where it's like you're
doing something you shouldn't and allah
doesn't owe you anything because you're
the creation he's the creator but you
get that type of like real-time feedback
what do you mean by real-time feedback
real-time feedback that's like if you're
doing something that you know you
shouldn't be doing it's like you notice
the effects right away
um
yeah there's always
like you have that argument in your
consciousness
you just know that you're going against
your goals or your values
and i'm relating a lot of
what you've just said then to my
experiences and the things like the red
pill and so it's that idea that um
if for example you go off your purpose
you'll notice that women just are less
attracted to you they'll treat you with
less respect
and i can see that happening with
everything that you do the people that
you come across friends family
the way that you work
so it's interesting that i can see that
link and like you said like you can see
truths in
the red pill
yeah but
like he was saying it all comes back to
taqwa like if you don't have the guy
consciousness then
you're not aware of this
feedback
right like it'll happen in front of you
and like to you you're just
you're ignorant to it you can't see it
it's almost like there's a veil covering
it
and it's not until it gets
like terrible terrible to where you
realize oh there's something off here
like look at the guy who's doing
nofap
all right like let's say he goes several
weeks he's feeling good he's feeling
confident
he's out there you know talking
socializing
getting those numbers doing all this
good stuff right
he has a slip up
and he relapses
okay inherently in the beginning he's
not gonna see anything but there are
things that are happening right there
and then like instant feedback which if
he had got consciousness he would catch
on to it right then then
right but
then time progresses and let's say he
relapses again and then again and then
again so much to the point where now
he's back in this in the beginning he's
back to the point where he was before he
even
uh started or maybe he's worse
and now he can see oh damn like there's
definitely something that happened here
because now life isn't the same as when
i was
several weeks on nofap and it's like if
he had the guy consciousness he would
have caught on to it immediately he
could have altered his direction and
what i wanted to say earlier i
remembered
is that
with the guy consciousness
since it's always there like the
accountability is always there like bro
before we even started this live stream
the first thing i was like telling you
about like oh you're doing a great job
and then i said something about like
i was gonna say plips
and like if you think about it okay it's
not that big of a deal but the thing is
like to me i have got conscious i know
god's watching and i know i'm going to
be held accountable for everything i do
everything i say everything i think
everything in general so when i i'm
about to say something like that i'm
like whoa like i gotta hold myself like
even if it's not that big of a deal
i don't know that at the end of the day
so it's like i gotta make sure that
you know i'm dotting all my
eyes and crossing all my t's here
because
being watched 24 7.
and that's that's the beauty brush the
beauty of god consciousness like
if you have that accountability like
what does that do to you as a man you
know what i'm saying
and i want to say that it's it's not
fear-mongering whatsoever it's not being
controlled or anything because people
people want to say oh i don't want to be
muslim i don't want to follow organize
religion because i want to be free
bro people don't realize that if you're
not following a religion you're still
following something everyone had even
atheists i don't believe personally
anyone communicates right
everyone's still making something their
god right allah says in the quran have
you seen the one that makes their nafs
their
their desires their god right so every
single person you you know you can't
tell me otherwise i challenge someone to
tell me you you don't believe and and
make something your god something your
god encompass right
but in islam there's
we we understand what's right and wrong
objectively right we don't have to make
things up like anh was saying about this
taqwa too i want to touch on a point
that there's a huge misconception that
people have that you know that are in
the red pill sphere right they think
that when you become religious you now
have to let go of pleasure and sexual
desires and all this listen there i'm
not gonna lie right there are religions
bro there are religions not so you know
definitely not god um imposing this
right this is self-made man-made ideals
right but there are religions that have
self-imposed celibacy right i don't know
where they got this from definitely not
from allah right like if you want to be
a member of this one house of god or
this community you have to you know give
up your sexual desires but then you see
the byproduct of that in them abusing
little boys bro you know what i mean so
um what i'm saying is there's there's
sexual desires and intimacy is something
very natural
you know sent to our fitrah by allah
and in islam we don't shy away from
these things bro there was a group of
little boys in the prophet saw some went
to them and said um you know if you will
have the ability to get married get
married right
um if you can then fast because fasting
diminishes sexual power
this is extremely powerful because
we are told from a young age right if we
are above you know age of you know
puberty and you know we have the
provisioning we have the ability to get
married get married don't wait on this
right in red you know sphere and and you
know this whole manosphere in general
the ones that are not on deen they're
like oh i want to have i want to spin on
my plates i want to bro you want to spin
plates in islam you can have four wives
because allah the creator has literally
created you and he understands your
natural fitra this is not some man-made
ideology or religion like i mentioned
before where it's like you have to be
monogamous no
women have to be monogamous right and
we'll get to that in a bit why they have
to be monogamous why there's a
difference not because we hate women or
misogynist um and why men can be
polygamous right a lot of things like
assuring paternity and you know all that
other stuff
but the tldr is we don't have shyness
towards intimacy right we don't have but
we don't have promiscuity that's the
thing because when you're promiscuous it
literally destroys and erupts your soul
and you get to a point where there's no
accountability anymore there's no
responsibility anymore
um the red pills
you youtubers they like to talk about
you know don't get with thoughts don't
do this but
little do they know that every time
you're promiscuous and you're like okay
i'm gonna wait till i'm i'm 30 40 to get
married i'm just going to sleep with
this a bunch of women that i can you're
literally creating another damaged woman
bro to some extent because you have no
intention of being with her so every
time a woman um when a man too sleeps
with a partner and they don't you know
stay with them it's just a partner and
it kind of takes away at their soul a
bit you know have you had a little bit
of experience with that in in terms of
you know your videos you were talking
about promiscuity or casual sex ruins
your soul what did you mean by them
you know it was only when
i stopped having casual sex
while intoxicated so when i was having
casual sex sober so i stopped taking
drugs in
probably
2019 2020 and so all the times most of
the casual sex i had was while i was
like drunk and on like
mdma and everything and
when i started like you know i took a
step away from
uh drugs but then still continued having
casual sex and it was kind of like i
spoke about it on my earlier videos
where it was like my reward for
self-improvement
that instead of watching movies or
playing video games like on saturday or
something i'd go on tinder and go with
on a date with a girl it was then when
it was sober and i was a lot more
mindful and present than i realized like
how damaging it actually was that
i would find myself just like thinking
about 10 20 different girls you know
over the course of like a month or so
and like you get a random flash of them
and especially with girls that i truly
connected with and spend a lot of time
with
and
i could feel
like my soul my body my mind like
yearning for them and the connection was
there still to this day with with
multiple different girls i'll go about
my day maybe it'll happen in this
podcast you know i'll be doing something
completely random and it's like i feel
my body embrace her like we've truly
connected
and you're hit with this this incredibly
sad feeling that
now that connection isn't there because
it was always
it was the foundation was always correct
it was always through like this
degenerate idea of like oh you know we
just hooked up from a club
and
i feel a lot of pain from that
personally
okay okay
see
i get that bro and that's why when we
when we have a nikah people don't know
what a neca is you might know nikah is
basically the the ceremony that a man or
woman gets married islamically right
marriage in islam is not the same as you
know institutional
legalized marriage right i want to make
this very clear people in in the red
pill sphere they have this huge like
fear like i don't want to get married
she's going to take half your stuff and
listen in islam we don't have this we
don't have unfair alimony laws and
settlement laws and any of this in islam
getting married can literally take five
to ten minutes bro you need
uh two witnesses right this is an
islamic nick has done two witnesses you
need uh the p the permission of the the
woman's guardian or the father
and you need the the dari that's it bro
and you're done
but the main message is not how simple
it is to get married islam but the main
message is once you do it you have the
blessing of allah you have the barakah
of allah right that's what sets that
precedence just like you were saying
hooking up with casual women and doing
this you don't have that there because
it's not there you know you're not going
to fake it so you're going into it with
the expectation that is is set to
crumble bro things that that build you
know easily crumble just as as easily
bro but in in a marriage it's different
right but this is not the same type of
institutional marriage that i want to
make clear is the the heaviness is is
removed because you're married in the
eyes of allah not in terms of the
government and the law of the land which
it's kind of corrupt bro let's be honest
so what's the difference between nikka
and like a western marriage
well the thing with the western marriage
is
more of a business bro i hate to say it
right it all started with lawyers
realizing that you know most marriages
are failing and i believe those at the
top that are working with them know that
pushing this you know alphabet gang and
feminism propaganda and all of this is
just going to lead to more men being
feminine and women being masculine and
all that's gonna lead to is more
marriages crumbling but when they look
at you know the main incentive behind us
it's money bro divorce lawyers and
alimony lawyers make the most money one
of the highest you know paid jobs
in law
period this is undisputed but when you
look at an islamic marriage there is
none there's no divorce lawyers or
alimony settlements
divorce is permissible in islam right
but marriage is simpler
in an islamic marriage you have roles
and responsibilities right just like i
mentioned before
but
you have the blessing from allah the
barakah from allah and you guys are
together done and now intimacy is
permissible now
seeing her without her hijab is
permissible now
right in western marriage it's just an
institutional contract in a way right
there are other religions too which say
till death do your part where you can't
technically divorce right that's not
islam right allah if allah really is
your creator he understands your fitra
and your needs and divorce is
permissible bro it's it's disliked but
it's permissible why is it disliked
because if it wasn't disliked then we
would just willy-nilly right just get
married to whoever and just divorce them
later right so the wisdom behind that is
we shouldn't we should take it seriously
right but i also want you to understand
that in western marriage right
why do you see people in the west bro oh
i've been dating my girl for 10 years 15
years why don't you get married oh we're
just not there yet bro maybe the guy has
a fear that if we get married you know
this is what's gonna happen there's this
whole extravagance associated with
western marriage that you got to go down
on one knee you got to spend 50k on on
the ring itself then you got to spend
250k on the actual wedding if you don't
you're cheap you know
and it's like i want you to understand
bro in an islamic marriage the prophet
of islam said that the best of marriages
are those that are cheaper like lower
you know in terms of they're not
extravagant in terms of how much you
invest in all that um and you have the
barakah first and foremost you won't
have to wonder is she with you because
she's a gold digger she only sees you as
this
sorry
the the barker
blessing
you you have the blessing from allah
this is this is first and foremost the
most important thing about the nikah
right and you have that contract it's
set in stone
with allah with that god level
accountability that you're talking about
not just okay i have to maintain this
and and whatever you know how many
people are in sexless marriages and and
completely destroyed marriages in
western marriages but they don't want to
leave because they know she's going to
take 500k if i leave right in islam we
don't have them right so there's a huge
stark contrast between
western marriage and anika
okay how does it work with a man having
multiple wives
give me give me a better
look at that smile on her bro
give me a better question um
like elaborate that a bit
uh because you mentioned it before so um
a man can have four wives yeah a woman
can't i assume that's because of
provisioning
not just provisioning so there's a lot
of things so
in islam plural marriage or polygamy
specifically i want to say polygyny
right because polygamy just means
multiple partners polygyny is one man
with multiple partners right
um this is permissible in islam and it's
the sunnah sunnah meaning the prophet
peace be upon him did it right it's
a way of his life
this is permissible in islam and it's
also favorable at times so i'll say this
how does it work well a man makes an
account with all of them just like i
mentioned right the wisdom behind it is
a lot of things so number one
one man
multiple women
let's talk about war let's talk about
times where women don't have there's
more you know women period right
you look at you know secular studies
they already proved is that you know
there's more women than men right
at times of war in times of hardships
right you know that cycle where it's
like good men create time yeah all that
right so
we're in that cycle right now where the
society is headed to where we have weak
men and they've created hard times
that's going to create you know even
look at what's happening in ukraine and
russia right
there's an inevitability in just the way
that the dunya works that we're always
going to have more women and less men so
plural marriage is a solution to that by
not having women that are not looked out
after not provided for not taken care of
not protected etc etc right
the second thing i want to say is it's a
man's innate fitra to provide just like
you were saying bro you know how you
were i think you made it in a video
where you're like a man has to provide
and a good woman right you made an
unfiltered video you said that
submissiveness is not a bad thing
necessarily and
nurturing and protecting the house is a
good thing right so i want to say that
for a man it's naturally fitra to
provide a man wants to be provided for
and to be appreciated right on his
provisioning a woman's not really the
same way can she work of course right
islam doesn't prohibit women working but
all i'm saying is it's in a man's fitra
or nature to want to provide so if a man
provides right multiple women he can
take care of multiple women women right
um furthermore it's sunnah to
you know get married to
women that have
that are single mothers right and this
is a huge thing that uh that you know we
can go down this rabbit hole another
podcast right because a lot of people
are like why why you know is it a sunnah
to marry single mothers or widows or etc
right so we'll talk about that for sure
because uh
it's the practice
that's um
romney
my mind is terrible
of the prophet
is the way of the the prophet the way of
the prophet
you know and it's a sunnah we'll talk
about that in another episode right yeah
but that's a really yeah that's a really
interesting point actually yeah yeah
it's so it's it's recommended it's no
it's not recommended
it's no one's it's not record there's
not a specific recommendation um to
marrying but it's it's a sunnah right
there's a lot of sunnahs that are
recommendations but we could talk about
that later too but it's allowed a single
mother in the west more times than not
might not necessarily be the same as a
single mother in islam right we look at
all these women and men that are not
taking accountability for their
sexuality and their their
virtue in a way but in islam we don't
have that right so it's different but
anyway
that's solved
provisioning protected protection all
that salt a lot of people are wondering
why can't it be the other way around why
can a woman have multiple men well
there's this huge issue of the assurance
of paternity right if you have one man
sleeping with multiple women
everyone knows who the mother and father
is of all the kids women never have this
innate
i guess concern that men have right you
know what i'm talking about that isn't
my kid
because a kid physiologically like a
baby literally physiologically comes out
a woman she doesn't have any doubt in
the world it's like 50 hertz in terms of
genetic composition
a man does not yes i know today in this
whole satanic world that we live in
there's you know paternity tests and all
this i'm not talking about that right
but a woman never and andrew t talked
about this in a video that he made he
said that the way things were once upon
a time was to guarantee purity right
so you look at women and men
when a man has multiple wives he can
guarantee all of the kids are his
and a woman can each of the women can
guarantee this is my kid
but when you have it the other way
around you can't guarantee that if a
woman has multiple partners multiple men
you can't guarantee which kid is who's
like who's the father islam um
fatherhood kinship lineage right this is
huge this is of utmost importance
because we need to know who the father
is you look at kids growing up today
statistics can show you know they grow
up without a father what happens to them
you know they grow up in single mother
homes what happens to them right and
islam we don't have that we don't we
don't even want to place the chance that
this could happen that's why it's not
that plural women uh plural marriage for
women is unrecommended it's haram it's
forbidden right
so for a man marrying it's practical for
a woman it's impractical mainly because
of the the whole you don't know who the
the father is but also think about
having kids bro
if one man wants to have let's say an
average of two kids rami said this in a
video and the woman wants to have four
husbands bro if i'm if a woman gets
pregnant once she's out of commission
for pretty much nine ten months bro you
know so for her to get pregnant again
let's say it'll take two years for the
first husband
for for both kids then she has to do it
again it's like it's not really
practical bro right and
plural marriage allegiance right one man
with multiple women
is only the thing that naturally makes
the most sense you see a lot of men in
the red pill sphere saying i just want
variety see
men and women are different in that too
right when a woman truly loves and
submits to a man she doesn't want
another man right but for a woman for a
man
if he truly loves you if he wants
another woman it doesn't mean he doesn't
love you as much as you know he says he
does it's just an innate fitrah type of
you know hardwired mechanisms bro we
can't control that
yeah yeah i just want to jump in really
quickly i don't want to say too much i
want to overburden the brothers because
a lot was said
but uh
the best way to define things like this
and explain things like this is with the
quran how it's built so i'm going to try
and make it very clear inshallah when i
come to nikah
we are required to have a proper wedding
islam two male witnesses
a bridal gift or a dowry or we call it
for the woman
the protector the guardian usually the
father or brother or uncle of the woman
the marriage contract and the groom
i don't think i'm missing anything
that's what's required for an islamic
marriage
if a if a man does this he's basically
taking the the position of guardian from
the brother father uncle
upon himself and essentially saying i
will provide and take care of and
protect
your daughter your sister whoever it is
that's his responsibility now if he does
this times four which four is the max
and i'll go we'll talk about that then
he has four is before
one one time
yeah
yeah yeah so
he's basically saying
that i will take care of this woman
times four for his four wives that's
essentially what it is the only reason
we're really having this discussion is
in the west we are monogamous if in the
west we were religionists then we
wouldn't talk about it wouldn't be an
issue it would just be how it is
but i just want to throw it out there
when it comes to prison god says in the
quran
mary in twos threes and fours
but if you cannot be just between them
if you cannot be fair between them
meaning you provide basically equally to
them you give equal time to them you're
fair and just if you can't be just and
fair then marry only one it's a direct
command from god so only men who are in
a certain position who are capable
uh of actually being fair with their
wives
are allowed to men who don't have that
ability are not allowed to
and look how beautiful that is bro like
you get in the car you're taking the
ownership of like okay i'm the one that
has to take care of her i'm the one that
has to provide i'm the one that has to
do all this
and it's like look for men
we develop under pressure
it's in us you know like if we don't
have pressure we have a comfortable life
like
brother if i'm if i'm here at my parents
house and i have all the luxuries in the
world all the food that i could want
and i can make money i can make all the
money that i want through here like
i'm sorry but it's not gonna be the same
as if
like you said in your video as if you
got a girl and you got her pregnant and
you got this kid on the way
it changes the dynamic it changes the
way that you see things like it
basically
to put it in simple terms it lights a
fire under your ass and like the most
growth that we as men
uh experience is when we are under
pressure so i think that right there
that's very beautiful
that the man is taking
that uh responsibility when you do marry
a woman and
it's very important to say this here
because i was
one of the guys that when i saw that we
could marry four women in islam i was
like oh boy i'm so like sign me up
you know i think it's very important to
say that
it can't be
out of desire
like
you you can't say i desire to be with
multiple women so therefore i'm going to
marry multiple women because again like
rami said in the quran god says very
clearly if you can't
be just if you can't support them don't
do it it's it's going to end very
horribly if you do he's saying it very
clearly right there and then as well
you have to understand like your
intention matters most
so if your intention to get married to
multiple women
is just to fulfill your sexual desires
bro like this
there's gonna be some issues
but like fire was saying if you have
these women
who they have kids
and they no longer are married and they
just have they have no one to provide
for them to protect them to do any of
this stuff
at that point that's no longer a desire
now you are taking on another
responsibility to be able to take care
of this woman and the children that
she's bringing as well
and um
i guess the last thing i want to say is
that
if a man truly would do this right if a
man were to truly
uh be with multiple women not out of
desire but because
he's genuinely doing it for the sake of
god like he genuinely wants to help he
wants to provide and um protect these
people these women and these children
like
imagine the growth that this
man would occur
incur i should say
that's crazy
that's the thing bro it's not it's not
just desire right oh no like there has
to be something more bro that has to be
that accountability and in islam bro
being intimate with your wife that's
literally an act of worship bro this is
something a lot of people don't know
like you literally get good deeds for
sleeping with your wife
and you get bad deeds for naught and for
sleeping with someone that's not your
wife
like how how amazing is that bro because
people think that we got to be over
pious so we we got to be shamed for
sexual intimacy no bro
it just we have
we have a virtuous way of doing things
um
i like the sound of all this i'm not
gonna lie
i've seen some arguments against this
and i actually had like a little debate
with a couple of my friends about this
and
you know it made me realize that
this is going on in the west anyway like
pollutionary like this idea okay one man
with multiple women well it's exactly
what's happening right now it's exactly
what i've been doing but i would just
have the extra responsibility to like
look after those women
it's
like i'm coming from you know western
perspective right now and it's strangely
like
um it's the opposite of what i can
imagine like some feminist who's arguing
with this point where she says it's like
it's sexist towards women
the west is like what we're doing right
now around we're like one you know chad
is sleeping with a bunch of girls
well how is that not bad then
if this is just okay well now that guy
should take responsibility for you
should take ownership of you that makes
him more of a man the women that he
wants to sleep with now get way more of
his commitments
literally bro 100 that's that's all it
is bro in in the west you look at
celebrities you look at high value men
right
they have a work wife
they have a side thing they have that
booty call they have the three and they
have their main thing it's like in islam
there's nothing done you know behind the
scenes there's no dirty business bro
it's all out in the in the forefront and
because it's out in the eyes of allah
anyway right so so why go around doing
all these these sneaky business anyway
right so it's like you have that four as
a cap at simultaneous right you can
marry more than four wives but not at
the same time
so a man must only have four wives
simultaneously maximum
but he can be monogamous if he chooses
to right some prophets were monogamous
some prophets were polygamous it's fine
right but for a woman you know it
doesn't work the same way i also want to
with rami and hope
i do want to go over some of the
fundamentals about islam
but before that do you have any
questions bro because i know last time
you said you had some questions
can you teach me how to pray
of course boys bro we got you man we got
we did you right here bro on stream
we'll do it on stream bro we'll do it
live um let's get romney getting ready
bro
do you want to kind of go over what
prayer is how it's not just
the secular spiritual it is a spiritual
connection but it's not just about you
but it's actually worship and you want
to then talk about like how we as
muslims why we pray and just go into
that yeah so firstly i want to say
salazar speaking of prayer in general is
is a friday prayer we attend uh every
friday it's obligatory for men and
coming up soon so i'm going to have to
bounce sooner but to answer the question
the word we use in arabic when we talk
about oh teach me how to pray
you don't need someone to teach you how
to you know
talk to god from your heart you're just
like hey god you know thank you for what
you've given me i appreciate it can you
give me this
you know this this and that success in
my business could help you don't need
someone to teach you that what we're
referring to is something called salah
salah linguistically means connection
right and it's literally a connection
with god in a way and
we have five days a day you know they
say muslims pray five times a day we
have five obligatory prayers a day you
can pay more if you want you could pray
recommended prayers and stuff but at
least five obligations uh or obligatory
prayers so
dura
is the word we use for kind of calling
on god speaking to him in a kind of uh
more i would say christian sense of the
word prayer we only have the word prayer
in english right
but in in
in islam in arabic like i mentioned
salah is more specific so what salah is
is it's a dedicated prayer at a certain
time of the day for example fajr is an
hour or so before sunrise maghrib is
during sunset isha is later in the night
and then you have like asir which is
like the midday prayer and dohur which
is like the afternoon prayer
and you have a certain amount of time to
pray these prayers and it's good it
takes discipline and it's it's beautiful
so what you do is you go
basically i'm not going to go through
the full prayer but you say allahu akbar
which means god is greater
and the blessing in saying that god is
greater and not just the greatest is
you're not just a sabbath god is the
greatest you're establishing that
anything that comes to mind god is
greater than that
so you say allahu akbar and you do
something called techbirds which you put
your hands up like this and you
basically stand like this with your
right hand folded over your left a right
arm folded over your left and you recite
which uh should i research somebody go
for a gopher go for it bro we'll send
you some videos too on our group chat so
don't worry about you know how to pray
all right
feel free to close your eyes inshaallah
if it helps
[Music]
[Music]
we recite every single time we pray and
it basically translates to praises to
god alhamdulillah praises to god the
rabbi mean the lord of all of the worlds
everything that exists
is the one who is generally merciful to
every all of his creation
in this life that's what rahman is and
ar-rahim is the especially merciful who
gives mercy to those who go there go out
of their way to seek it
owner of the day of judgment
you alone we worship
and when we say you alone we worship
what we're also saying is you are the
only one i obey i don't make my own laws
i don't let the government i mean we
obey the law of the land but i don't let
them tell me what's morally right what's
morally wrong in my religion in my life
i that's god's job and i accept god
and you alone we ask for help we know
that we can ask people for help but it's
not going to come to us unless god wills
who have earned your anger or nor those
who have went astray
so you could see that the first the hot
first half is praising god the second
half is asking god
so it's almost like a dua like you're
praying like you're asking god for
things after you praise him
and then the rest of it you know we go
we bow basically to god we put our head
on the floor to god and when we have our
head on the floor we say it's
means praises to god the most high so
when our highest point is at the lowest
part of the ground the world the ground
the lowest part we say praise is to god
the most high establishing that god is
the highest and compared to god we're
basically nothing
and it's very very beautiful and we'll
go more in depth into it insha'allah so
you can establish that connection but we
pray because god tells us to pray
we know that there is wisdom behind it
we know that there's benefits behind it
we know that it it increases us
spiritually it blesses us mentally
and even physically certain positions
that you enter in are good for your you
know you're back in certain body parts
even like going in a bowing position it
you know strengthens the legs in the
back
and
uh although we do it for the sake of god
it does have those uh those kind of
benefits but regardless we'll go with
more into depth insha'allah soon yeah
yeah we all gotta bounce soon
i wanted to say
bro you got look at that smile on
hamza's face bro look at that mashallah
bro little do you know there was a
companion of the prophet saw hamza hamza
radhila
and he was the chad bro you know we're
talking about donnis and all that hamza
was the man the warrior right so
ramadan is around the corner too bro
ramadan is in about a week ramadan is
the month where the quran was revealed
the month where we fast as muslims right
i'm sure you know about it
um
other self-improvement youtubers like
ali apos which we've had elliot house on
an episode for those of you that didn't
watch that and i am lucid you know they
fasted for ramadan and you know ramadan
is genuinely where you unplug it's kind
of like a dopamine detox and you plug
into out of the dunya right and the
reason i'm telling you this is because
remember how rami said that we pray
because allah told us to pray we also
fast because allah told us to fast the
scientific studies on on meditation
mindfulness fasting right
on your hormones and your mental health
it's it's unlimited bro but what i'm
saying is we do this because allah told
us to do it bro
and
the best deeds to allah are those that
he has made obligatory right the most
favored deeds right so the things that
allah has made obligatory how wonderful
is it that those are the things that are
best for us and allah loves them the
most but if only we knew bro
but just hearing that that basic uh you
know ada z that rami gave you about
praying
you know is there anything on your mind
it sounded beautiful i didn't realize it
would be like a song
it's melodious yeah it's melodious
yeah allah commands us to recite the
quran in a beautiful melodious fashion
and some say even recite it in a serious
way where it's almost tear-jerking
because what you're reciting is not like
you know
i had a great day and you know i love my
life what you're reciting is is the
truth it's you know
like keep us on the straight path why
because there's you know hell exists and
i don't want to burn there i don't want
to be punished i want to do exactly what
i was meant to do
which is worship god submit to him and
hopefully get to jannah these are very
you know passion inducing things these
are very important things which is why
it is recited in that way but
alhamdulillah bro the beauty is in the
recitation the beauty is in the quran
from the word of allah to allah so
beautiful man it's a beautiful thing
talk to us
i feel good i appreciate you guys
sharing this wisdom with me it's been a
very very uh interesting and positive
conversation
of course bro of course i also wanted to
say that i want to give you like a
personal invitation bro the ramadan is
around the corner bro in about a week
you know try it out bro you don't have
to you know be the best at it but
i genuinely want to say for me and i
know for an hour too because angel made
you know he's been a muslim for about a
year year and a half just over that
and when he fasted for ramadan it was
transformative ron how do you want to
talk about you know your journey in
ramadan
yeah i keep it like because i mean i
made videos on this but
it's number one is humbling
because like bro like you're not eating
and like people people are fasting you
know some people have been like oh how
fast i have done like a water fast nah
but like have you done a dry fast
from sunrise actually before sunrise
is before the morning prayer because the
morning prayer hits like an hour or so
before sunrise and
once that morning prairie hits like you
can't eat you can't drink anything so
imagine that an hour before sunrise you
can't eat or drink anything all the way
up until sunset
not many people have done that outside
of islam you know and i speak for myself
yeah i never did that
so when i did it it was um
at first i realized oh this is not as
hard
as i thought it would be
and then from there on out it's like
bro like you know how like
you have these little moments throughout
the day and i'm not talking about why
you fast i'm just talking about like in
general you know you have like little
moments throughout the day
where you
[Music]
you just kind of reflect and you might
realize something you're like oh damn
like that's crazy and it makes a very
big impact on you
and
i don't know just like maybe something
in your childhood you remember something
in your childhood and then it's like you
process it and because you processed it
it's like
some healing occurred you know what i'm
saying you're just like present right
yeah yeah well i mean you could say like
that but it's like there's something
that happens in that little moment in
time that brief little period
bro when you're doing
this dry fasting
literally
for
how many hours is it
it's it's from fajr to margaret right
before fajr so basically how much time
it depends on where you are bro because
some people have more daylight some
people have less but let's say for us in
the uk or for us in the west here fudger
is around let's say 5 6 a.m so you you
have to stop eating at like 4 or 5 a.m
and you have to go to about sunset time
which is like anywhere from like seven
to maybe even eight nine pm in the
summer
so it's tough bro oh that's that's
13 15
give or take
13 to 15
hours
where you are literally in that
self-reflective
state if you so wish to be in
even if you don't want to be in it it's
still there like it's happening like
there's so much healing and there's so
much that's like happening well i can't
even explain it man like after that one
month
i don't know man i i personally i never
was the same i'll say that yeah it is
beautiful and bro honestly in some
places the sun sets and rises at very
specific time so they fast for like 18
hours a day yeah literally crazy but um
yeah i gotta i do gotta bounce i wanna
ask one question for the brother before
i go and after this i really do have to
go inshaallah so uh habibi hamza
where are you in terms of islam like
when you look at islam because you say
like this is all beautiful and i think a
part of you also realizes that this
can't really just come from a you know a
man who couldn't read it right in the
desert 1400 years ago you know what i
mean like this kind of
this kind of
practicality this kind of blessing this
kind of guidance this kind of beauty
cannot come from a man who couldn't read
or write in the desert 1400 years ago
and from people who like like if you
look at like the eskimos today
conquering america and russia that would
be crazy the small band of arabs between
sheepherding
arab arab people in the middle of the
desert ended up with the religion and
worshiping god conquering rome and
persia and basically the entire world
which in their power remained in power
for like 1300 years we know that things
like this in the guidance and beauty
cannot come from a single man or even a
group of men i don't know look at redpaw
what they're trying to do they can't
even produce
half or i would say they can't even
produce 10 of what islam offers bro and
islam is definitive they're kind of all
over the place and that's just one group
of people in the 21st century so where
are you in terms of coming back to islam
um
seems like it's a
uh
a process
like it's not something i could just
like jump into i can't imagine it's
something that'll be quick
uh with everything you guys are saying
with for example praying and fasting
it's like my mind's automatically seeing
the progressive overload variation so
it's like instead of passing for the
entire month try it for a day or try it
with water but not with food and i'm
taking like the
um
what what feels
less friction for me
because it it seems like a huge
lifestyle change and you guys know it
when like we were actually supposed to
have a pro podcast previously and it
literally bailed beforehand because like
the pressure got to me and i literally
like i got symptoms of being sick and
like trauma and everything like just
uprising because
as i said it in um
i think it was one of our messages in
the group chat like it's
it's extremely painful to have your
views challenged there's a lot of like
processing that needs to go on and i
need to spend like a couple of days with
my journal so one of the ideas that i
did get is after this conversation i'm
sure we'll speak and i'm gonna organize
like a couple of days i'm just like i'm
away for technology all i've got is just
like a pen and a piece of paper
and i'm just going to see what comes out
that's beautiful bro
and thank you man for sharing that i had
to ask bro like after this call i'm like
i need to know this guy's you know
spiritually it's a beautiful thing do
you have a quran in your house no okay
okay if she doesn't then i'll send you
inshallah uh translation of the quran i
know a really good one inshallah so
we're gonna send you one uh and and just
give it give it a read bro honestly if
we're talking like top tier evidence for
islam it's going to be that book in sha
allah but that being said humble bro it
was a pleasure i know we're going to
talk plenty in the future brothers may
allah bless you all to everyone here
since i won't be here to say that
yes
[Music]
bro
listen you say you take all the time
that you need
as much as you need
alright keyword
um reflect on it bro
journal
but when it comes to the the dry fasting
um if you choose to do so
just know god will make it easy for you
like again it sounds crazy like yo i'm
not gonna eat a drink
for like 13 to 15 hours like bro
trust like i know
i know it sounds crazy
before um actually i won't even say that
it doesn't even matter but the whole
point of it is that like if you choose
to do so
god will make it easy for you and like i
said
that one day
could turn a two could turn a three
could turn to a week could turn to the
entire month you know what i'm saying so
just you know take take the time you
need reflect on it
and
yeah just rip the band-aid off
at least do one day
um
yeah thank you for saying that
yes yeah bro and i want to say one thing
too that that's the quran bro i'll send
you some other stuff too and
the whole thing about prayer bro salah
jesus peace be upon him moses peace be
upon him muhammad peace be upon him all
of these prophets right
um
some religions held them to higher you
know ranks than just prophets but we
know they're all just prophets all of
them prayed the same way bro all of them
prayed just like rami was saying and
they put their head on the floor bro
if you're truly sincere bro and and
here's the he's the key thing bro truly
sincere
and you generally you don't have to put
your head down on the floor but if you
have like a prayer man you want to do it
i highly recommend you do it and just
pray to god
right you don't have to say allah
because allah already knows who you're
talking to bro
it's just one god bro
conversation between you and him and
just sincerely ask to be guided bro
i guarantee you if you're sincerely
asking to be guided you will be guided
bro inshallah god willing
but that's the thing you have to have
that sincerity you can't just be
wanting to do it for some other affair
or some other intention you need to you
know if you generally see that this is
it
and
i'm not even saying to be guided to
islam bro just genuinely ask allah to be
guided to the straight path
and i'm shawn has been doing this well
before he was muslim and
i can generally say aha was one of the
many people that i know that were
genuinely guided to islam they didn't
guide themselves into it but they were
guided and i think that's that's also
different because in the
self-improvement journey most of the
dunya things we have to lead ourselves
right to have a good physique to have
money it's we have to be in charge but
for things like this it's kind of like
the yin yang it's kind of like the
opposing force where we have to like let
go and let god almost in a way so it's a
little bit of a mindset shift too from
the usual i guess goals and aspirations
that you have but i generally think bro
it'll
it will genuinely be the best decision
that you will make
for you dunya for this life and for the
hereafter bro and
me angel were all attest to that fact
bro
so
if there's any more questions for you
let us know bro
yeah thank you um nothing's coming in
mind in terms of questions but i
appreciate the
conversation
i was about to say bro like
even if you had more questions i don't
even want to hear them not because i
don't want to hear them but because it's
like
all the answers the real answers is
gonna come from the self-reflection like
being by yourself disconnecting from
everything you know like bro personally
i want to tell you everything
i want to just like throw it on you but
i know that's not the way and i know
that like
as humans we become overwhelmed like
this
and like bro no one likes someone
telling them what to do and all that
stuff like so again like bro you take
your time
you reflect on it all the answers will
come to you
when you reflect on it sincerely
yeah yeah bro and in about a week or two
or you know as soon as you know we can
all make the time
we'll do another podcast definitely on
you know stuff like entrepreneurship
fitness and all that i think a lot of
the brothers they need to hear this
stuff
so we'll definitely reach out to you
make this happen but if that's all we
got some q a right now and then we can
wrap it up bro
instead
all right
oh no bro you want to read it
what's the ideal timeline for nofap
right
now are you asking when to start or it's
just like timeline in general timeline i
guess to like heal or recover
oh that depends
it depends everyone's different someone
might heal up in a week
someone might take years
it all depends on like how long they've
been doing it for how deep were they
doing
like how many times were they doing it
it's
too many variables to just say ah
three months
you know what i'm saying
what about you
yeah i totally agree the nofap
community online is uh
i think pretty toxic and i really don't
like the the idea of this nofap benefits
timeline but i've heavily criticized in
the the youtubers before because telling
a guy like oh you gotta get to day seven
or day twenty or day ninety you'll start
levity and i think it's total yes and i
think it's like so
um
so cold-hearted because the analogy i
gave is imagine telling like an obese
guy who's you know he's he's heard about
the negative effects of being obese and
imagine telling him okay go to the gym
for seven days and you know do this 20
days he'll do this 30 days we'll do this
and if you miss a day you lose all those
benefits
that's well that's not true at all like
the guy who who faps
every single day once twice a day and he
goes
two three days without it and he relapse
he should feel like a success because of
that progress that he made not like a
failure and i personally i think the
idea of like watching nofap videos and i
think the the nofap benefits timeline i
think it just makes these guys way more
obsessed over and it creates more of a
negative impact in them um
right and just think about it man like
imagine you have someone telling you
um at day 20 you're going to feel this
at day 40 this
90 days this and then imagine you
getting to that and you don't feel me
well then you're going to think ah it's
not working i might as well not do this
i might as well just go
and uh continue what i was doing before
it's like no bro like everyone is
different
you might you might not experience that
at all
or it just might take you longer you
know like your healing is always going
to look different than another person's
healing
so i agree with that wholeheartedly
yes is this live or recorded oh this is
pre-recorded bro we had this back in
time and we found a way to like put your
comment you know in real time i don't
know how we did that
all right
brother rashad apart from subscribers
and viewers this is the hamza what
moment or sign indicated that you
uh to you that you were gonna make it as
a full-time youtuber also hamzan
filtered over hamza yo i've been saying
that
one moment indicated that i was going to
make it full-time as a youtuber brows i
was about 14 years old
i was posting videos about um
minecraft runescape and i remember i got
partnered with this like media company
called tgn if this was i think even
before like youtube adsense or something
like that or maybe they had like lower
um
requirements and so imagine being 14 15
years old in high school and you
literally start getting paid 50 pounds
100 pounds a month for your cringy
little minecraft videos and from that
moment there was no career no job for me
whatsoever i went through high school
college and even university without ever
once even considering like the jobs that
i could get it literally was not in my
mind it was always going to be a
youtuber
see i struggle personally man
i struggle because like
you know how you said you didn't expect
for the channel to like blow up
yeah well now you have this big audience
and it's like you know you hardly even
take the time to change what you're
wearing before the next video
right so it's like
sometimes it's like when you really
start to think like man i have all these
people like imagine being in front of
200 000 300 000 people and it's like
what you're saying holds so much power
and so much value
and so much repercussion
right like you could be literally
you could say something that could
really push someone through a lot of
pain and suffering and like you would
have no idea
right so like sometimes i struggle to
make more content because like i'm like
damn
like i don't want to like overstep my
boundaries and
at the same time like i realize that i
don't know everything so sometimes i'm
like
damn like
i really don't know what i'm talking
about here so should i even talk about
this
and then it's like bro one week passes
two week passes do we pass it so
it's tough man but i feel you on like
youtube being like another thing for you
what was your moments
when i realized that i could do youtube
full-time
uh i'll be honest man it was actually
before i even started youtube
um i was watching youtube videos
and i
remember running across elliot host's
videos
and i was like yo this guy's the man bro
like i love his videos it's like always
so much value back in the day like still
you know he still gets value but like
the old elliot like yo elliott and then
you got the
the musicals come on bro like there was
nothing like that man
and then i seen that and i was like yo
like this is so crazy
and then around that same time is when i
started having issues with uh the girl
that i was with and then i realized i
actually had an addiction to pornography
and then i started looking up on youtube
because like like a degenerate the first
place i'm gonna go to is youtube
and um i've started finding other people
had the same problem and then i started
seeing like people actually posting
videos about this i'm like yo like
people are posting videos about this and
i'm seeing people like living full time
off youtube i was like
what if just maybe
i could share my experience
not only help people but actually
make a living to where i could travel i
could do whatever i want and not have to
work at like
some
you know physical location or something
or for someone else
and then from there like it's just like
it was a long way coming you know long
time coming but
it happened bro
thank you
we got about 16 minutes left so we're
just going to try to blast through it uh
amman writes i left islam in 2019 after
contemplating it throughout my teenage
years only to revert back in 2021 on the
what advice would you give somebody
actively trying to follow some other
than just the five pillars on her bro
anything
so this is a big one
uh your connection
to god
and the way that i would classify this
is you really have to sit back and like
reflect on your life as like what's
bringing you away from god because
in the quran god says that he's closer
to us in our jugular vein
that's pretty damn close if you think
about it
so if if god never moves if god's always
this close to us if you feel far away
from god we'll realize that he's not the
one that moved you are and that's when
you got to reflect okay what what am i
doing that's pulling me away from god
like maybe you're spending too much time
on electronics maybe you are
um i don't know maybe you're actually
doing substances like you're doing drugs
or something like that maybe you're
just not reading the book itself
you know there's so many variables that
could come into play here but
really figuring that out and then
starting to cut those things out and
understand that when you cut something
out you have to
include something in you you can't
remove something without
replacing it you always have to replace
it if not
your body is going to be like yo like
what the hell is going on
so if you're removing these things
then you replace it with something
that's going to bring you closer to the
creator so that could be spending more
time in nature
that could be not only doing the
obligatory prayer
but then doing the sunnah prayer the
prayer that's
recommended right and then on top of
that you know making dua doing vic
there's so many things but it's like you
you have to replace the things that
you are removing and that will
ultimately bring you closer to the
creator and then you having this
relationship with the creator
it puts you in a state of
high iman
um
if you want to explain what that is
a lot of people have an a misconception
that iman means faith right but in islam
we don't just have blind faith
iman is linguistically means acceptance
of a fact bro
and it's iman is just the relative
submission you've you've had to like
fully consolidate islam is like the
truth that's the only way i could put it
so iman is like the confidence or the
surety but it's not even like a mental
thing it's more like a feeling
exactly and with iman you go through
states like high iman low iman
and the closer you are to the creator
the higher this iman is
and i mean you wouldn't really have a
problem with
islam or your deen or anything like that
at that point
all right bro proper
rasheed writes god is always there and
loves us and loves those who do their
best let's get back to john 100 percent
arshid reza's lovely brothers
just arrived but great to see hamza on
this conversation
100 percent
um okay so zuhib you wrote this question
and you wrote this other question so
just for the sake of time just dm us on
instagram at the three muslims one word
and rami who handles all the you know dm
inquiries and you know guidance and
advice and all that he'll hook you up
inshallah
okay
ashraf writes
where do you guys study the religion
again same thing just dms and instagram
the same way you just typed it right
there
i realized
i i put my last name
like i realized i just cooked myself by
putting my last name
it's okay i put my full name on here bro
bro people already know your full name
yeah you're right that's that's all good
bro no surf rights if you're spinning
plates someone else has to do the dishes
forever
that's deep bro that's deep
man allah
all right my rights humzo this is a
sticker twist moments ah if you know
first man you know twist and the
afterlife is where you cash out
shout out to chris tony for watching 100
100
rayon writes i was born a muslim and i
still consider myself a muslim just got
a little distracted after moving to the
west how do i get back to dean again
again just dm us on instagram the three
muslims one word and we'll hook you up
and sha allah links in the description
to all of that
but let's see if there's any more
yeah that should be it
no i'm so
it's been a pleasure man it really has
we finally got to have this stream and i
look forward to more streams with you
you know
and we can talk about a lot of different
stuff bro that
the brothers really do need help with
bro like money entrepreneurship
fitness diet i watched some of your
fitness videos bro and diet videos and i
could really see like
you're not trying to give cookie cutter
mainstream advice you know saying how
hollywood and the mainstream modern
fitness industry
all the misconceptions all the bs that
they're spewing out it's good stuff bro
so anyone that is from our channel
and you know they want to get more of
you bro working the head out too
uh just search hamster on youtube i'm
the top result now
i love being able to say that
yeah yeah bro that's it you don't have
to say hums or what nah just just search
thumbs up bro
[Music]
all right
y'all hey i bet you everyone's gonna
read that and say my name in like the
most whitest name possible
why don't you won't you tell them how to
pronounce it in uh
my name yeah my name is pronounced angel
why don't you say your full name bro
your full government name i mean at this
point you might have no my my full
government name is angel
but like my family name is miguel
um there we go yeah but
they don't got to know that you know
you're giving these sisters fitness bro
with the way your you know your native
tongue bro
we're gonna stop that now
yo so hamza bro
the uh unfiltered stuff
it's the good stuff bro
[Music]
um it feels better
is coming up
yeah but it feels better doesn't it just
like actually speaking and then
not trying to make it entertaining just
you're being real you know
well that's the beauty of youtube when
you literally just stick the camera on
no script no nothing just whatever's on
your mind and people actually want to
listen to you talk
i love you sir
yes sir
it reminded me of like times of my and
broke financially
in as an entrepreneur bro and i know the
same with you bro we're nowhere where we
want to be by any means
but one thing that you know one wisdom
that i can share is
when you stop relying too much on the
money and you're too obsessed with the
money
it's like you lose that detachment from
the money it doesn't define you you talk
about this in your unfiltered videos but
you're just making enough and then you
don't need the money you don't rely on
the money the only thing we should rely
on is allah but it's like when you don't
need that money
allah can finally trust you with more
and then you get more barakah you know
what i mean and i found that to be true
like nine times out of nine but you need
the money then you make decisions based
on the money you do things compromising
your integrity your manhood and it's
like you do that with women you do that
with money the dunya you're not gonna
get those things bro but if you detach
from the dunya allah is gonna bless you
with more
totally agree with that i've got a video
talking about that soon actually but um
when you don't need money is when you'll
make the most and of course it's biased
because you don't need it because you're
probably making a good amount already
and it all scales up but that's when you
get to make those truly long term
beneficial decisions instead of what's
just quickly going to make you the most
this week or this month
you think differently too
you know you you think
um
just how you said but it's like
i'm not explaining that like you think
he is more creative and it's just
it produces better
results better content
thank you
what do you mean thank you for
supporting
we should follow the advice of hans on
making youtube videos bro don't don't
add that filler stuff that's going to
lower the the engagement bro just know
when to end it everyone's clicked off
now
yeah all right so with that being said
hamza bro
it has been
it's been amazing you having you on
you know god willing we will speak again
god willing bro you you tried the dry
fasting and
i'm excited to see you know what comes
to you during your reflections
and with that being said
for everyone watching thank you for
tuning in
um
romney already said is uh dua so
i'm not gonna say anything else on that
like button bro smash that like button
hit that subscribe button head over to
hamza's channel show him some love too
and with that being said salaam alaikum
thank you for having me on boys
take care everyone adios bro